Campaign people who have talents like music.
I saw a lady with a camera.
We need to promote those people.
It's not just about pushing gender departments.
What about the students
after you leave gender departments?
I am here to see how we can give
opportunity for creativity to everybody standing there.
And as I land up,
don't let this election
get your mind off the examination election.
But remember,
we have the examination right behind the corner.
So please, on March 1st,
vote in Rashid.
I promise you,
it's my team.
Check my cabinets.
Of course, I prioritize women so much.
And show you both.
Tim Rashid. Yes,
please. For the sake of God.
Tim Rashid. Please,
please, please.
I don't have much to say.
I just want to tell you guys that
I am lonely at the top
and I need everybody here
to see how we can do things together
and then show you you have the right thing.
Lonely at the top. Lonely,
lonely, lonely.
Money on Mama. Money,
money, money.